bonsoir parata kenya merci de répondre à
nos questions sur rt france calme et 15
millions de personnes vulnérables
vacciner donc outre outre manche ce qui
démontre une bonne organisation
logistique était doses qui sont
présentes contrairement à certains pays
européens comment est ce que vous
expliquez cela grâce à l'armée notamment
le résultat d'efforts coordonnés par
farid de d'assurer l'approvisionnement
la résine très important car sa cause on
ne peut pas avoir deux programmes
efficaces donc avec les doses nous avons
également un système médical bien en
place avec des médecins généralistes et
un réseau qui les soutient plus les
grands hôpitaux
c'est grâce à cela que nous avons obtenu
ces résultats et cela contraste bien
avec les erreurs des programmes de
caisse et de traçage qui était organisée
au niveau privé donc la leçon à retenir
c'est que les services le pot du nhs
fonctionne mieux
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
donne sur l'homologation d'urgence aux
vaccins du laboratoire britannique au
suédois astrazeneca ce soir ou en france
il ya beaucoup de polémiques autour de
ce vaccin
d'ailleurs une nouvelle campagne de
vaccination pourrait être organisée à
l'automne selon le gouvernement
britannique est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il ya
un problème d'efficacité contre contre
les variants astrazeneca hawkswood
vaccine britain's pour astrazeneca très
protégée et si j'étais en france je ne
dirai mieux vaut lui qui ne sait que de
ne pas l'utiliser
je ne dis pas que la france a tort je
dis que tu as non sens et serait plus
efficace utilisé un vaccin qui empêche
de développer des formes graves de la
maladie et que sauver des vies le point
important du vaccin
s'agissant de changements qu'on pourrait
apporter aux vaccins ce n'est pas un
problème majeur car les virus on le sait
ont lutté peuvent changer et au fur et à
mesure des ses mutations de ces
changements nous pouvons reformuler les
vaccins existants afin qu'il protège
contre ces nouvelles mutations
ce n'est pas un problème majeur et c'est
tout à fait faisable comment est-ce que
vous accueillez les nouvelles
dispositions aux frontières annoncées
par le gouvernement britannique deux
tests pcr quarantaine à à l'hôtel cela
va être très compliqué car qui d'abord
il faut être scientifique qu'un autre
accroche refont nous il est bas les
personnes à la frontière du royaume
certains passionnés l'historique chacun
mais n'importe quelle peut être inscrit
sur cette liste donc il faut être très
prudent
il faut également être très prudent sur
un autre point dans ses étals il faudra
avoir des contrôles des barrières
sanitaire efficace car sinon d hôtel
rempli de personnes
un carottage peuvent se transformer en
foyer de contagion d'une chambre à
l'autre du côté de la grande bretagne on
attend le 22 février lundi prochain avec
une nouvelle feuille de route du
gouvernement
dans quel état d'esprit sont les
britanniques la population britannique
je ne me mets pas nos affaires en
fonction des dates les devants je fier
aux chiffres à celle ci les chiffres
montrent que les autos réflexion non
baisse que le taux d'hospitalisation de
baisse et que la population supporte
lyon c'est une bonne chose
notre comportement ne devait pas être
déterminée par les dates les par les
données dernière question le premier
ministre boris johnson a parlé d'une
sortie progressive mais irréversible
est-ce qu'on peut être agir de la sorte
quand on sait qu'il y a des variants le
mot variance et varié donc être
irréversibles comme ça quand on voit le
début de la crise sanitaire depuis un an
ça change tout le temps on peut vraiment
être irréversibles sur right and writing
vous avez raison dantec goût du jeu
parce que ce n'est pas sympa usage du
mot irréversible car lorsqu'on lutter
contre des maladies contagieuses
on doit prendre les décisions en
fonction de là aussi de la baisse les
contagions fait être prêt à revenir sur
ses décisions en l'espace de quelques
mois il a vu effectivement au royaume
uni
le royaume-uni a lancé un premier
confirme c'est un deuxième puis un
troisième
rien est irréversible merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions à battants kenya
je rappelle que vous êtes expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université
d'exeter en grande bretagne